grève de jour pour dénoncer des
conditions d'apprentissage
insupportable.
Bédard.- - - - - - - - - - - - ,
de l'école du Hazay.JeJeJeJe mer
parce que j'apprends à l'instant
que votre enfant a été positif.
pour ce directeur d'école
primaire depuis la ren
scolaire le 3 janvier dernier.
OLIVIER FILIPO, directeur,
- Il va falloir que je fasse
un mail à toupapapaparents en
disant : trois tests. Ils vont
être contents, les parents.
semaine, c'est la règle en
France dè'u'u'u'un cas de COVID
est déclaré dans une classe.
- C'est l'enfer déjà pour les
une classe et que je dis :
bo é é é é écoutez, voilà, vos
parents vont venir vous chercher
parce qu'il y a un cas positif
des enfants qui se mettent
pleurer.
- La colère de ce directeur
d'établissement, Maylis laéeéeée
à la maison parce que Margot,l',
a contracté la COVID-19 dans
sa classe de maternell d d d d t
aussi enseignante au primaire.
La maladie de sa fille,
elle la vit plutôt bien.
Mais la successirororororororors
dans les écoles, beaucoup moins.
MAYLIS JACQUIN TURLAY
- En une semaine, ça a changé
quatre foit t t t t t t t t t tr
les parents ni pour les
enseignants.
- La dernière version des
mesules écoles leur a été annone
en direct à la télévision.
Un allègement des exigences
pour répondre aux vives
des parents à bout de souffle.
Il n'est dorénavant plus
nécessaire de passer en
pharmacie ou en laboratoire où
au-delà d'une heure pour
effectuer un premier tes
MAYLIS JACQUIN TURLAY,
enseignante
une illusion qu'il se passe
quelque chose. Mai
réalité, c'est des gens qui vont
remplir des papiers pour
des écoles ou aux enseignants
sans faire les
- Elle est loin d'être seule
dans sa profession à en avoir
contestation inédit s'organise
chez sesgugugugugugues. Ce jeud,
environ 75 % des enseignants et
directeurs des écoles de France
- La demande, c'est que l'État
r r r r r r responsabilités et
sécurise les écoles pour que
les personnels et les enfants
- Et à un gouvernement quirmrmre
garder les écoles ouvertes, eux
se disent tout à fait  q q q q .
- Le ministre se plaît à dire :s
uniques, nous ne fermons pas
les écoles, les clas
Est-ce que vous pensez
réellement, sérieusement qu'une
classe fonctionne quand vousara,
deux él u u u u u u une classe?
- Cette fois, et c'est chose
rare, le personnel scolaire peut
compter sur un app
nombreux parents d'élèves.
NADIA REZGUI, maman de Camille
- Si les gens ne sont pas dans .
Donc il ne faut pas avoir
la chose à son échelle en se
disant : "Moi, j'aurai une t t e
compliqué." Il faut ê
solidaire de tout le monde.
- Ce mouvement est hquququququqn
peut plus, quoi. O
faire notre métier comme il
faut, mais tout va bien.
donc tout va bien.
- Dans ces paroles, on entend
bien l'écho du désarro